[Music]
all right let's go out to celisa in
Austin Texas what's up
celisa hello how are you paryan what are
you up
to trying to deal with the teen years
good luck with that all the help I can
get yeah good good luck I was about to
call you
and yeah I day by day trying to figure
this out um hoping I value your advice a
lot and so I'm hoping um you can give me
some helpful tips here it's something
we've kind of been um dealing with for a
few years now um so basically my
question in a nutshell and I can dive in
but um my question is how do my husband
and I help to encourage and support our
16-year-old son while he's struggling
kind of on a day-to-day basis with a few
different Dynamics um I'll dive into a
few of those um he's
recently kind of L lost his best friend
and group of friends uh he's struggling
a lot to be at school and be in that
environment he really doesn't have much
of a relationship with his biological
father and so that's been coming up a
lot lately in the last probably two
years and then you know my husband and I
now his stepfather were trying to kind
of create a space where he can process
all of these things that are kind of
going on in his life while kind of
teaching him to have some type of
purpose and not go down these negative
um paths while he's processing and
dealing with all this so that's a lot to
unpack um but curious on any advice
there on on all of this yeah I got a lot
of thoughts here this I mean this is
this is um I have a a 14-year-old and
I've have I mean this has been my
careers working with um these folks and
so um why did why did his why did he
lose his best friend in his gang what
happened um basically there was some
drama that um happened last year in
school where somebody created a rumor
about my son and his girlfriend and it
really stirred up a lot of drama with
his friend group and they kind of all
didn't want to have anything to do with
it so they took off and really have him
come back around and his best friend
ended up kind of choosing that side
instead of him okay so it's been tricky
and I think really hurtful for him and
there was um I I
find 14 15 16 17 18 year olds pounce on
rumors and pounce
on um
like Big T like big like William Wallace
statements yeah but when those things
are found to be untrue they Circle back
real fast so is there any truth at all
to
this no no there was no truth and I
think it was created probably in
jealousy um but nobody's really come
back around and I think my son has
really kind of just internalized and not
really decided to put himself out there
again um you know whether it's making
new friends or talking to other people
or reaching back out I think he really
is just I think he's hurting about it
but he's not really willing to do much
about it at this point and I think we've
kind of pushed him to think about hey
there other you know kids clubs or
groups or church groups or things that
you could maybe be a part of where you
have the opportunity to meet other
people um and this is kind of where I
think my husband and I struggle is what
we think is maybe the helpful solution
he's just not ready for yet and so
there's been really no action on his
part
I got one more question for you tell me
about this you're helping him find his
purpose and process this what does that
look like yeah so I think um kind of how
we've been approaching that is one we
have started him in counseling and he's
been on and off with that for a little
bit and we just recently um my husband
and myself and our son have been going
together to kind of work through some of
this and then the other piece of the
processing peace I think is just having
really like open communication with him
and feeling like hey if there's anything
you want to talk about or if there's
books you want to read or any way we can
help you dive into the emotions you're
having we're here but that's kind of
where my question comes in is I don't
want to feel like we're over pushing and
to the point where he kind of uh pulls
more away and so you know maybe we're
just totally missing some areas that we
could really help him and that's
where're now I appreciate your care
there and I here's what I want you to
know without a
doubt you are following the The Playbook
perfectly and I think if we were to look
at 18 to 24 year olds 18 to 25 year olds
we have to be honest that the Playbook
doesn't
work because here's what you've done you
have a a son who went through something
I'm going to be honest with you I've
worked with young people my whole life
with teenagers and college students high
school kids and college students it's
very rare that someone creates a
myth with no truth to it and every
friend Burns him to the
ground sure that's very hard so I don't
know if there's an unwillingness I don't
want to see it or no Mom I promise I
promise and he's just our precious
little baby boy or if this is one of
those rare moments that somebody just
flat made something up about him and his
girlfriend and he lost everything that's
very rare okay uh and that's just me
that's just my experience there but it
could have happened that way here we
are what a 16-year-old is incapable of
doing contrary to what the Playbook
would tell us is sitting down by
themselves and waiting through their
thoughts and feelings and
emotions and rationally landing on a
series of steps to take
next they can't do that there's 16
what a 16-year-old has to do is has to
be pushed into they have to do
things yes counseling can be important
for you and your husband and him to
learn how to talk but here's where we
gets in this weird reciprocal cycle it's
it's going to turn into a spiral really
actually already is but it goes into a
spiral real fast here it is what it is
he pulls away a little bit and feels a
little bit syrupy I don't want to I'm
not ready yet and what do you and your
husband do you all put something else on
the table well we'll go to counseling
we'll do this thing we'll help you if
you want to do this I'm going to pull
away a little bit more and then we're
going to do and so what he's getting all
what he's getting every little step of
the way is exactly what his body is
craving which is an adult to tell him I
love you and I see you yeah and his dad
cut a hole in his heart by being gone
right yeah yes so what he does I'll just
walk through a couple things he
desperately desperately needs number one
he needs you daily touch you're my son
I'm going to hold your face every single
day oh come on Mom come on I'm gonna
hold your face every single day I'm
gonna look you in the eyes and tell you
I'm so glad that God picked me to be
your your
mom the second thing is is once a week I
want youall to have some sort of I'm
going to call it a date but you know
what I mean like you take him to
breakfast you you do dinner with just
you two yeah because there's that very
strange thing that if he feels him s
gravitating towards his stepfather who
sounds like he's a great guy and good
good man yeah okay that there's that
disloyalty to his biod dad right EXA
that's exactly what he said several
times that he has always felt like he
can't even call him dad because that's
the connection he has really the only
connection he has with his actual dad so
that's right that's right and that's
it's a it's a but often we try to solve
that by forcing new Dad into that
picture you can reinforce it from the
inside out with
you okay you can strengthen that
relationship okay yeah he now the second
thing he's going to need is he has to
have a strong male role
model if not one multiple probably
multiple
right most of the time kids in this
situation some can make the leap to
stepdad they can some can't and that's
where coaches Jiu-Jitsu coaches So
guitar teachers somebody who he actively
is involved with on a regular
basis and so in my house I'll just I'm
just tell you what I do in my house my
kids have two options they can do one
art and they have to do one art and they
have to do one
movement that's just a thing and the art
can be an instrument the art can be um
which both my kids have chosen and then
as my kids one of my kids got older uh
chose theater but they have to do
something expressive where they have to
learn how to create and they have to
learn how to create with a team and
there's a lot of stuff about neural
connectivity and all that kind of stuff
that is like playing instrument all
that's important and yeah they have to
do something with their body does your
son play sports has any involvement
anything movement wise yeah he plays
soccer at his high school and so he's
pretty involved with that and pretty
active and he's got no friends on the
soccer
team no and that's kind of the you know
I'll ask him like what about this kid
what about that and I see you kind of
hanging out with them around soccer why
don't you ask them to go do something or
um you know our son's driving now so
that opens up a little bit more freedom
um and he's just like e like I've asked
him and they just tell me they're busy
and kind of blow me off so I think he
just feels like how much do I keep
pushing if they don't want with
me yeah I just don't believe him and I
don't I don't I don't not believe him
like as though he's but I don't believe
him in like the
um something doesn't ring true
there something's not ring true sure
they may say no I'm busy cool well what
are we going do next time and here's how
I would handle that if I'm you if I'm
you or here I would handle that in my
house um my son runs cross country hey
here's the deal son I'm inviting the
cross country team over for dinner I'm
doing that you can pick three or four
people to come over or I'm inviting the
whole team you get to pick
now my son would be like invite
everybody that but that's just kind of
how he rolls my daughter would be a
little bit
different but I think we both we you and
I both know the importance of
relationships for for teenagers period
And so I'm not just going to Outsource
that to my 16-year-old and say well you
got to go make some friends you got to
make some friends no I'm a parent I'm G
to get involved and that's not an overly
dramatic like I'm over no I'm going to
start having people over to my house I'm
just going to because there has to be
something there's something in the water
here that's just not ringing true with
me um but he's got to have movement
related things and he's got to have a
relationship with that coach and if it's
not coming through soccer then maybe
he's got to do something
else and the final thing would be this
um and I think let me say this I think
you're right about group activities I
think you're right about um getting
involved with church groups and things
like that I think that all that stuff is
good all that that stuff is good give
him a chance to be successful with other
friends the final thing is this I do
think your stepfather plays a
role and if it's a matter of saying dad
or calling him Steve or Dan or whatever
that's not a battle that's not a hill I
would die on at this
point but we're looking for is um we
want a picture of what that looks like
of what a male relationship with your
16-year-old son looks like and so that
might mean that your husband begins to
take him out to breakfast and it starts
on breakfast one is I know you feel like
you're betraying your dad and so I'm not
trying to get in the middle of
that that's your dad and that's for
y'all two to work out
together but we live in the same house
together so we're going to be friends
and I'm G to get involved that way and
there's going to be a constant here's
the key a NeverEnding show up I'm GNA
show up I'm gonna show up I'm GNA show
up and he's going to show up your
husband's going to show up he's going to
show up and your son is going to do what
he can over time to push him away and
it's not going to work because I love
you
kid and what your son is going to learn
in real time oh this is what being a man
actually looks like because my dad
abandoned me and until he can metabolize
that it's going to be tough a tough road
to hoe for him but your husband's going
to show him this is what men do they
keep showing up for their sons they keep
showing up they keep showing up they
treat their their mom like this they pay
their bills like this they do a budget
like this and so maybe it's just life
lessons hey I'm G teach you how budgets
work I'm G teach you how how a household
runs I'm going to teach you how to fix a
car I'm going to teach you some things
but we got to have those relationships
and it might be hey I'm going to start
taking Jiu-Jitsu after soccer season's
over I want you to take it with me um
we're gonna do it together um and you
can call me Steve call me Steve all the
way through if you're never comfortable
calling me dad that's fine I'm not going
to force that um and I think it's good
for him to keep seeing a counselor about
his dad because his dad left him and
that's going to leave a a dad sized hole
in that heart for a long long time but
what we're looking for now that he's 16
we're looking for him when he's 22
24 and he's able to feel inside his
nervous system but also look back in
memory and say oh no no I got a picture
of a man who kept showing up it was my
stepdad I got a picture of a mom who
never ever let me
pass she grabbed my face every single
day and said I love
you my parents made me have friends it
was so awward and so weird and they made
me I'm so glad they
did right now we have a lot of talking
and a lot of how do you feel and a lot
of processing let's begin to move
towards action the processing is still
important having that conversation is
still good I recommend putting a spiral
notebook on his bed and you you and him
can go back and forth or the three of
you can go back and forth and writing
things down that tends to be a little
bit more of a uh an honest way to
communicate with a teenager sometimes
because everything sucks or it's the
worst or I'm fine um sometimes writing
it down is very
helpful um letting them see that you're
grateful for them letting them see that
it was a really hard day together but I
love you and I'm confident tomorrow's
going to be a better day letting him see
that and read it and then have to write
back to you today was fine today was
okay I really wish that fill in the
blank whatever that is but that may be a
good way to you all communicate together
and continue to process this stuff
together but let's move towards
action let's move towards movement let's
move towards action let's move towards
relationship yeah not just thinking
about or thinking about it and feeling
about it I'm going send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life I want you
to check that book out as a family and
maybe that'll give you all a road map
towards kind of what I'm talking about
here